please welcome
the magnanimous jennifer aniston
[Applause]
for some of that
[Applause]
hi
this is
first of all seeing you in the in the
flesh because i've been watching this
and you're so good
you're so good
at this honestly i love every single bit
of it you get stains out of you i mean i
oh someone said to me
oh what was what is it
well i've already put a stain on your
chair because in my body makeup
you're like dying for that right this
has been in your blood for a long time
yes yes it really did start when i was
like
14 living in my first apartment and
there was a laundromat down the street
and i would get into that
washer like it was a cauldron and i was
a witch
fabric softener stain removal bleach the
whole art of and i think that's where it
was born so it also holds the sentence
14 my own apartment
it's you know we're this girl has lived
it well we're going through a journey
today yes and i wanted to take this
intimate tour of los angeles
that really showed
every place that i've lived do you still
have the house that i've been to a few
times i sold it actually i know that was
a very painful thing for me a very scary
thing for me to leave my one anchor that
was your anchor when you moved from new
york
to l.a yeah
what were the feelings what was that
experience like
to let go and start anew yeah well
let go and start a new i don't think
anybody moving going from new york to la
evers actually says i'm moving you there
you're going on a vacation
that then just keeps extending itself
because you're almost too afraid to say
as an actor i'm gonna go try to make it
in california because if i didn't make
it in new york for two years god knows
i'm gonna make it in la so i'm just
gonna go visit my father and then i
landed and i knew one person
and then i met another person
who then let introduced me and then i
went to this little
party like a little house party in
laurel canyon maybe 12 people next thing
you know
i'm in a goddess circle
in laurel canyon
and i all of a sudden had someone i
couldn't just talk you have a talking
stick
i was like wow i am really i have landed
in los angeles
and then i was i i got a job at a
telemarketing company like in what east
i don't even know where it was
uh selling selling pocono timeshares
and then i did get a a job so i moved
from studio city
where i met these people these were this
group of people and they all had rentals
on this street in laurel canyon called
beach knoll road yep um
one lived here one lived here one lived
here and they would all sort of visit
each other there was one house that
everyone kind of congregated in
and then one night i was there they're
like this one's available for rent
so then i got myself up on the hill
and we were called the hill people
lived this fun few years doing jobs here
and there and
then friends happened which i thought i
kind of manifested because i said this
is sort of the way i live on the hill
where
you have your friends
and everybody shows up at the house
at monica and rachel's
i was like i feel very this is very
familiar to me do you believe
that you do manifest things like one is
capable of manifesting
i've been told
to manifest you whatever it is that you
are wanting to manifest
you
you speak to it as though it's already
happened okay i like that
so thank you for
this wonderful job
that i have
dreamed about and prayed for
and i with this glorious crew and a
joyful experience thank you for that
now
it's hard to like pass by the career
that you've had and jump to the next one
and then we're going to go backwards but
adam sandler
who is
someone
that the sandman the sandman the man can
adam is he's one of a kind isn't he he's
a unicorn yes he really is he's a
unicorn because he's a joy he walks with
joy lives with joy and he doesn't get
moody yeah comedians are moody and i'm
attracted to them because i want them to
make me laugh in real life yes and let
your girlfriends do that yeah totally
yeah okay so there was this uh twitter
debate that happened about who is a
better partner for adam sandler jennifer
aniston or drew barrymore which sounds
weird to say my name
and
what i loved about what came out of that
was what
well that you and i chose each other oh
well that's a no-brainer
yeah that's because
you know the there's the the
the phrase the guys like to say you know
bros before hoes oh my god i was gonna
say hoes before bros always
and that is sisterhood that's right and
we have had that
and you have it with your friends and we
just celebrate that and i loved that
that was the true answer
[Music]
you